that's what how to be oh we are gonna
find out tonight but can we go back to
last night for a second because Hannah
came face to face with Peter for the
first time since she dumped him and as
if we needed another reason to love her
Hannah beast drops another windmill
bombshell because of you two nobody will
ever look at a windmill the same and
with that bachelor nation collectively
lost its mind and oh yeah that's Peter's
proud parents sitting just feet away but
we're also calling this latest windmill
shocker clue number one in our et
investigation does the Bachelorette end
up alone let's be real if Hannah was
actually happily engaged to either Tyler
or Jed would she be joking about hooking
up with an axe on national TV are you
engaged I would say I'm really like I'm
really happy for the opportunity I had
adding fuel to the speculation Hannah
single this raw moment on stage last
night the past couple of months have
been really tough and emotional so what
could have gone wrong for Alabama Hannah
well host Chris Harrison straight-up
said tonight Jed will be at the hot seat
this after ET exclusively interviewed a
woman who says they were still dating
when he went on the show this is a
person that I'm very much in love with
telling me I love you I'm not gonna fall
for her clearly there's been a lot of
accusations been a lot of things said
about Jed I want to hear him answer some
questions and I'm gonna push him this
mayor songwriter confessed to Hannah
that he went on The Bachelor hoping to
boost his career and last night it was
apparent that Hannah's parents were not
impressed with Jed he has qualities my
most major accomplishment is that I
signed a deal with
dog food company sure yeah we found that
dog food jingle but back to our deep
dive into Hannah's relationship status
we'd also like to point out that we
didn't see Jed or Tyler ask Hannah's
parents for her hand in marriage and
then there's this teaser for tonight
Oh would you ever be ready to be engaged
former bachelorette Ali Fedotowsky has
seen part of tonight's finale and pretty
much confirmed our suspicions it does
not end the way it normally does would
you say there's a happy ending of sorts
I cannot answer that question
aah what is gonna happen Kevin it might
be the most dramatic Bachelorette finale
ever and tomorrow we're gonna be with
Miss Hannah B and her new man or
possibly not a man I don't think she's
gonna date anyone she doesn't need a man
[Music]